let's go to five headlines
[Music]
okay and here's another one of these the
daily wire reports a black lives matter
protester allegedly pulled a gun on a
truck in indianapolis
in indianapolis late last week as the
truck tried to get around a group of
protesters that were occupying the road
a video of the incident went viral on
social media over the weekend
but the incident appears to have
happened last thursday here's the video
get that baby
[Music]
come on buddy don't be stupid
[Music]
what you have to understand here is that
these leftist
quote-unquote protesters they
have been driven so mad by their own
sense of entitlement
they have gone so crazy with entitlement
that they they really at this point
don't even understand
uh the concept of they they stand in the
middle of the road with a gun and
pointed out
at a driver they really think they have
a right to do that
they they really i believe that they
actually believe they have a right to do
it
which is why if you ever say to them you
know you're not supposed to do it what
do you mean
what do you mean i can't do this this is
this this is this is freedom
stop being a fascist they really don't
get it
because as i said they have quite
literally been driven mad by their sense
of entitlement number two um speaking of
madness report in the ap
says riverdale nursing home in the bronx
appears on paper to have escaped the
worst of the coronavirus pandemic with
an official count
of just four deaths in its 146 bed
facility
the truth according to the home is far
worse 21 dead
most transported to hospitals before
they succumbed
it was a cascading effect administrator
emily um
fuziov recalled one after the other new
york's coronavirus death toll
in nursing homes already among the
highest in the nation could actually be
a significant undercount
unlike every other state with major
outbreaks new york only counts residents
who died on nursing home property and
not those who were transported to
hospitals and died there
the statistic could add thousands to the
state's official care
care home death toll of just 6 600 but
so far the administration of democratic
governor andrew cuomo has refused to
divulge the number leading to
speculation that the state is
manipulating the figures
to make it appear it is doing a better
better job than other states
and um making a tragic situation less
dire so this is
i mean nothing to see here just
you know we start with government
policies that directly killed thousands
and now we go to a an actual conspiracy
to cover up how
bad the damage is and governor cuomo is
just sailing through this no problem at
all
no problem at all for him
you know that's that's democratic
privilege for you number three my
personal favorite
musical artist akashi69 a poet and
musician even more brilliant and
insightful in cardi b if you can believe
it
is causing controversy today not because
of his lyrics or because he's a
convicted violent felon who only escaped
a half century in prison because he
turned around and snitched on the other
gang members and his crew
not because of that but because he wrote
a subway without a mask
[Music]
watch
this is
just shocking behavior there shocking
but and this is what people are upset
about uh and it goes back to what i what
i said at the top about
even though you know if you criticize
pop music or whatever
it is that takashi six nine does
you're always going to be you're gonna
have people scoffing at you and it's
like oh just just relax it's just
it's just music you snowflake yet these
are the people that are offended by
everything in this case they're offended
by a guy
because he's not wearing a mask on the
subway um and
and and i i didn't even mention in the
cardi b song
actually there has been some leftist
backlash against the song it's got
nothing to do with
the celebration of the objectification
of women
um it's two reasons number one kylie
jenner is in the song
and that's a controversy i have no idea
why i think it's just it's literally
just because she's white
so there are people that are upset that
a white person is in the song
and uh also that there's tigers there
are uh big cats and
and so and so um uh you know the tiger
carol baskin chimed in and other animal
rights people have been offended but so
those are the two things we're
we're worried about we're worried about
the tigers and we're worried that uh a
white person was allowed in in the video
because you can't you can't have any of
that okay
number four the huffington post reports
a washington man was arrested on
saturday for allegedly assaulting a 72
year old veteran over a face mask
dispute
police apprehended cody hansen 35
at his home after he was reported the
july 18 incident left the unidentified
victim with a broken jaw and cornea
abrasion
and uh what happened is a partially
disabled
elderly veteran and he was they were uh
looks like they were at a hotel yeah
okay they were in the lobby of hotel
the the elderly man says something to
hansen's girlfriend because she wasn't
wearing a face mask and then hansen
later returns
and does this if you ever had any if you
had any hope or optimism
about humanity's chances in general or
its chances of surviving
some sort of apocalyptic situation
rebuilding society if you had any hope
about that it should be gone now uh just
based on this masked
stuff i mean really on on both sides
just
the way people are acting
violently assaulting each other over
wearing a mask or not wearing one
it's total lunacy number five um
well we've talked a lot about lunacy
let's go to a little a little a little
gleaming light just a small bit of a bit
of
sanity uh it's a small matter but i
think we have to
i tend to latch on to any sanity that i
see now and
because i gotta find hope somewhere so
this is from a deadline
reports the simpsons actor harry shearer
who gives voice to characters ranging
from elderly miser mr burns to the
unflappable of african-american
physician dr
julius hibbert isn't quite in agreement
with the long-running show's
recent decision to stop using white
actors for non-white characters
shearer this is what he said in an
interview on times radio
i have a very simple belief about acting
the job of the actor is to play someone
who they're not
wow that's a provocative that's
provocative these days
to just define what acting is is is
provocative and controversial and
actually
not everyone agrees a lot of people
don't agree the issue has been the
source of debate with regard to fox
is fox is the simpsons since
um the documentary the problem with a
poo and last year's
announcement by hank azaria that a pus
who's portrays
that he's going to step away from the
role um
though share pointed out that he was not
opining on whether the producer's recent
decision was mistake
he says that you know playing a range of
characters is the gig
that's the job description he continues
i think there's a conflation between
representation which is important
um shares suggested he disagree with
conflation between representation and
performance
people from all backgrounds should be
represented in the writing and producing
end of the business
so they help decide what stories to tell
and with
uh what knowledge but he adds again the
job is playing someone i'm not
and this this is there's there's nothing
to disagree with here it's
really basic common sense this is what
an actor does you pretend to be
something
that you're not but this is where we are
in our culture right now where
even this is an actor saying
my job is to pretend to be something i'm
not and this this is headline news
these days hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated